I am Arnaud Meunier I am the
director of the MC2 maison de la culture
de Grenoble
I arrived at the maison de la culture
de Grenoble in January 2021 which was
a somewhat special period
because the theaters were closed to the
public we were in full swing  second wave
and second covid confinement I
arrived in Grenoble after 10 years of
management in Saint-Étienne where I
developed for 10 years a
popular theater project by highlighting
and putting forward the values ​​of equal
opportunities for  inclusion I worked a lot on
the question of the relationship with the
working classes in a city which
was very particular because of a
former mining and industrial city
which had experienced a great shock we will say
at the end of the 90s so it
was a question  to ensure that the
Saint-Étienne clerk could embrace these
populations and invite them to share
the work tool which was the
national dramatic center when I arrived
in Grenoble in fact I applied with
the idea that this house of culture
had  was built on a
citizen spirit which sought
precisely to share culture for
all and I asked myself the question of how we
could
do that in a city which is
particularly strong since
on the one hand it  there is a
scientific
and engineering population here which is double the
national average so we have
populations here who are accustomed to a
level of artistic and
cultural demand who expect major
signatures and major
creative shows from a point of view.  national and
international view and at the same time we are
placed on a border what André
Malraux called at the time the
urban periphery which means that on
the other side we have cities and
neighborhoods which shelter populations
which are what  we call
priority neighborhoods and therefore a whole bunch of
populations which are generally
far from the environments of the creation of
art and culture so the project
was to ensure that the Maison de la
Culture could be a place of mixing
of mixing and meetings of
all the inhabitants of a territory
with their differences
and at the same time of potential appetite through
the artistic encounter
from my point of view
the United Kingdom conceals talents which have
often a very strongly
engaged connection with politics or with
politics in a broader way
and that inevitably when we run a
cultural center we want the
subjects that are brought on stage to
directly affect our
fellow citizens and our fellow citizens and they
are  that Grenoble is the
metropolitan territory Grenoble is also a
territory very strongly engaged on
political questions on questions
of transitions on questions
of equality of regard for others of
openness of sharing so it is
perhaps to this  place there was
a conjunction we will say between the
concerns of travel like cell and
MC2 and in fact we
realized that we had values ​​in common
among these values ​​there is indeed
this equality  chances this
search also for attention to the
youngest and most fragile and to what we
call diversity, that is to say to
ensure that in our rooms we are not
only between people of the same
social class and  of the same color and to
make our
spectators resemble as closely as possible
the diversity of societies of
French British society in which we
live
[Music]
I am someone who follows a
family which is not at all  a
family that is artistic so I
grew up in a very small village
between Cognac and Angoulême
called Saint-Hilaire so I know what
I owe to what we call
democratization, that is to say the  lucky
to have had artistic practices from
school to perhaps be able to
continue them in what was called a
music school and which one day opened
a theater class which
was not yet called a conservatory
of knowledge  that it is
theatrical practice I was able to continue them at
university and that at a given moment
I was able to branch off towards
higher education more specialized
in dramatic art and that it is the
conjunction of all this
extraordinary network which  allowed me to open
doors to meet what we
call the institution since the need
for culture is for example a
national scene so it is a
State label which means that we have missions  in
relation to the creation in relation to the
support for the emergence of new
forms in relation to the fact of trying
to share that with the
widest and most diverse audiences possible well
all of this was made possible for me
through this wealth  extraordinary
that France offers
so because I took advantage of all
these opportunities I am keen as an
artist as a
theater director and as director
of an institution to open the doors
and  windows for everyone else,
so that's what I try
to do on a daily basis with a
pricing policy that is extremely
proactive so that we can reach
out to those who do
n't necessarily have the means to pay and
shows to invent with
artists who are present on a daily basis
in the house in creation in connection with
the territory by giving workshops
awareness-raising actions
to invent with them how to weave
a story how to write
something that can  be of the order of
sensitivity with the inhabitants and the
inhabitants of a territory and then also
indeed to always seek what the
next step is, for example the fact
that youth are extremely
connected to the digital world
that the smartphone has become a sort
of natural extension of the arm and the
hand and therefore to say that
potentially there are also
areas of research and creation there
and that the institution must be a
vector of research and
deepening of
this rather than being afraid of its
new technology so it is in this
place of intimate and
militant conviction in a certain way and of
encounters with
artistic excellence that my daily commitment is located
as director
[Music]